and i'll play e-dog he's a long-time
supporter on my channel
and i'm going to play e4
let's try to make this more tactical
okay another modern
another modern so we're going to play it
exactly the same way that we played
the last game bishop to e3 okay this is
literally exactly the same this time
let's play h4
immediately it doesn't really matter the
order in which we play h4
as long as we play it at some point and
he actually responds in exactly the same
way so this is all the same
this is literally all the same as that
first game we played
and remember that in this position
ultimately black wants to develop his
bishop to b7
which is why we want to play the move f3
we want to buttress
and reinforce the pawn so we don't have
to worry about it and so that when the
bishop appears on b7
it's not actually immediately attacking
upon now could somebody remind me in
this position
somebody remind me in this position what
is the key maneuver that we play as a
consequence of him weakening a certain
square
so gigahertz for now i'm gonna not
develop the bishop at all
i don't need to yet let's see what he
does and then we will decide
where to put the bishop we can also
fianchetto the bishop that's not out of
the question
but we don't need to worry about it yet
whoa skye
bobbles another 500 bits girl
yeah nike fun absolutely and we might
play this a little bit differently from
that other game
uh just to show you guys the range of
ideas we may have
now what's on the docket for us here oh
my god
oh okay okay i just got baited
that's 500 bucks right there okay
so basically nice one siddhant
what should we do now in the in the name
of flexibility
between castling
and um developing the bishop which of
these should we prefer
and actually there's this oh i want to
show you guys a really interesting idea
i want to show you guys a really
interesting idea
in terms of developing this bishop as i
explained the first time
when we play bishop d3 we sever our
contact with the d4 pawn
so we we facilitate the move c5 we make
it stronger
when we castle what happens is he plays
c5
we can take on c5 and our control over
the d-file has been increased
which discourages him from playing c5
but there is a
third idea that we can play i'm going to
tell you guys the first move and i want
you to tell me the second
and i'm going to give you a hint it's
not bishop g2 where the hell is the
bishop actually
yeah what are we preparing with this
move
what are we like insinuating this is not
a move that i'm necessarily
going to play but it's a move that he's
now gonna have to reckon with for the
rest of the game
five thousand five dollars oh my god
yeah
sacrifice on e6 absolutely we might sack
on e6
break through his center and then win
the bishop on g7 that might be an idea
and i want to make it very clear that
we're not necessarily going to do it on
the next move or if we don't the idea
has failed
in fact we can even make it stronger so
let's calculate this should be six
takes knight takes e6 attack is queen
the problem is he moves his queen and
then when we play knight takes g7 he
goes king f7
i'll show this after the game the knight
is gonna be trapped so let us
prepare the idea of bishop takes e6 how
can we do that
how can we prepare bishop takes 66. you
guys are already familiar with this move
because we played it in the last game
well d5 he goes e5 yeah knight f4
knight f4 increases the pressure on the
pawn
remember that that's why we played 92
the knight is on its ideal square
notice that we haven't even castled yet
we haven't needed to the king is
perfectly fine in the center for now
if he finds a way to defend against this
stuff fine then we're going to castle
but right now we're prioritizing the
immediate attack
we want to just checkmate him here
okay
okay
so like yeah
whoa i mean if he goes up five already
beer whoa this pun
is going to be dead meat
it's gonna be toast so
he has i'm not gonna say the best move i
mean his best move is knight fa
his best move is knight fate which is a
very nasty move to play
because it it defeats his ability to
castle
let me tell you guys he cannot allow
knight takes c6 that would be a total
disaster
that's right flowerton that would be the
second best move let's just say
but allowing knight takes e6 is just
absolute devastation
uh zac ticks i don't think there is a
most people i think you can
run some statistics but everybody is
completely different
no i don't know e dog doesn't stream
snipe this guy's honorable but just in
case
uh but he's very honorable he doesn't
stream tonight
and i don't hold it against people if
they stream snipe what would the speed
run it's that that would be fine
so i mean oh my god okay that f8
now what is the idea of knight f8 what
does that move accomplish
what that accomplishes is it defends e6
it defends e6 so if we take on e6 twice
he's going to take back and we're not
going to have a knight any longer so
let's just develop our pieces by
castling
no i think he just found it i mean
that's that's a findable move
that's definitely a findable move let's
give him the benefit of the doubt
yeah guys e-dog is i'm not gonna have
shade thrown on him
so how did i why do i castle because
we're patient here we're not rushing
with any sacrifices we're just
increasing the pressure by completing
our development
okay so now we need to find a way to
increase
that pressure but we can actually
procrastinate in a good way
on that task we can procrastinate in a
good way on the task
chess procrastination involves playing a
healthy waiting move
when we castle we already talked at
length
uh about what kind of move that may be
so what is that healthy waiting move
king b1 yep
let's yeah so he takes but now his dark
squares are really weak
yes he makes this move less likely but
look at all these
dark squares that he's weakened by
giving up his like main bishop
okay he's attacking this font we can't
defend it directly but we can move this
knight away
where should we move it we should move
it toward the center so that it remains
relevant
and now our strategy should be to open
up the position
when our opponent gives up a very
important piece that supervises so many
squares
uh it's really important to open up the
position in order to be able to
take advantage of those squares now i
know a lot of you guys at this point are
thinking either e5 or d5 but we got to
be careful about these moves
because he can just go forward if we go
e5 he's going to go d5
if we go d5 he's going to go e5 there is
a third way
to open up the position yeah so we could
play f4 f5 that's one good idea
that's actually a great idea but c3
would be another c3 would be another way
to open up the position
okay which way should we take a bit of a
trick question
how should we say let's think think
think think
c takes c takes d3
excuse me two reasons
sorry wrong passageway
wrong passageway two reasons what do we
open up
look at the center we create look at how
we're now defending the e pawn
c file beautiful file we don't even need
to occupy it
but guess what we can let's employ this
rook on the c file
where does the other rook be long where
does the other rook belong
wrong tube yeah in russian you say wrong
throat
it belongs on the f file why does it
belong in the file because once we play
f5
we are going to stomp on his position
crunch
boom boom bang powdered
bing bang pow bing bang boom
and now what are we going to take on f5
with another trick question
don't rush if we were to play this
creatively dania style
we want to take with a rook because we
want to preserve this bishop as the main
attacker look at how his king is
completely caught on the crossfire
now we want to try to find avenues to
his kick what can we use to get to his
king well
we already have a rook on c1 if that's a
natural thing to follow up on
we just need to enhance the attack on
the on the pawn on c7 so the move is
bishop f4 bingo
now i look at this knight on h7 and i
say
it's a type 2 undefended piece only the
rook is defending the knight can we
attack that rook
using the piece that we just improved
yeah there's so many possible moves here
i don't want to create the impression
that there's only one way of winning
this i mean okay
now we ask ourselves what squares have
been left
behind as a result of this trade what
can we now do
absolutely queen she five and then rook
c6
sexy moves here his knight is lost and
he gets checkmated
boom and it's made in two his king
literally has no escape
checkmate that's how you oh that was a
rated game oh okay okay
i i thought for example for some reason
i was on my normal account
uh but yeah that's a nice game that's a
nice game
good game okay so that's why the modern
is such a hard opening to play the
modern is very hard to play because you
have to deal with
all of these weak squares right and
this idea of g3 bishop h3 is super
common
i've seen it before i'm sure i can find
games
right off the bat where where this has
been applied
this is almost an indistinguishable game
from my game against edoc
another sub zora okay so literally
similar line this is actually not my
game against e-dog this is literally
another game
g3 king b1 b3 to stop knight c4
bishop h3 92 knight f4
literally move by move same ideas now
black managed to castle long here black
god is king safe
but that doesn't diminish the the the
sort of the strength of this idea really
and and in the game white opens up the
game with d5 he opens up these files and
white went on with a to a crushing
victory white just has complete
dominance over the position
and white won the game in the end so
the point of bishop h3 is to increase
the pressure on the e6 pawn that doesn't
necessarily mean we will
definitely sacrifice on e6 but um
when you increase the pressure on
something you force your opponent to
worry about it
force your opponent to allocate
resources to its defense
and that raises the likelihood
that your opponent will end up being
weak on other sides of the board
this is a game between an international
master as you guys could see in a 2200.
now why didn't i take on e6 the reason i
didn't take on e6
is because if you extend the line if you
calculate the line
after knight g7 king f7 this knight is
actually trapped
and if we try to defend this knight with
bishop h6 black has a really sexy move
that um that dislodges the bishop from
h6 i still think white is much
better here i think white might be
winning but uh in
light of the next move things get very
complicated and i just didn't see a need
to do that
yeah nike a good job guys considering
the retreating moves
now this does allow queen f4 check but
now the other knight comes to f6
this gets super complex okay
so that's why we patiently played knight
f4
castles bishop h6 king b1 improving the
position
and now well bishop e6 here ezra
i'm not sure what you would accomplish
here i mean there's no bishop on g7 to
capture
and um you know i'm not sure exactly
what you would gain from this i mean why
could go d5 to establish
the knight on e6 but um i don't think
that's the whoa
gem gym 10. let's get that hype going
appreciate it jim jim 10 gifted to the
community
as i continue coughing
i need some water thank you so much jim
jim let's go
the train has left the station
basically knight c3 defending the pawn
and now several ways of opening the
position it really went down the wrong
tube
now c3 is my favorite way of doing that
because it attacks b4
and this is another application another
application
of the principle i have been emphasizing
whoa edok
3650 my gracious opponent gifting three
subs to the community
to kingdro420 junghash brown and
i'm brian lefevre my pleasure man thank
you for the gift i'd appreciate your
support
um why does this not
why does it not matter that we've opened
up the b file what principle
allows us to immediately unders
understand
that this is not dangerous for white
like how do i know that
how do i know that this is not dangerous
for me
no pieces first of all white has all
these pieces
masked together second of all
yeah i can even play rock h2 second of
all black has no pieces on the queen
side
black can't pull an attack out of his
behind i mean you need pieces on the
queen side
black is way too bogged down with all of
his weaknesses
to ever really even dream of a sustained
attack and
that's a very important thing to realize
no pieces in all talk
so f4 is what we did in the game in lcd
opening the c
file beefing up the security of our
central pawns that's what's important
here
not the optical sort of appeal of our
center
in fact if you learn to look at this the
right way this this should actually look
better than taking with the queen which
would not be bad this isn't like a super
significant decision
this would actually facilitate f5 so a
case could be made for queen takes d3
but cd i think is a little sexier
because we don't need to rush to prepare
f5 now f5
and now we can take with the bishop but
this is even stronger rook takes
preserving the bishop
twisting the knife and putting the
bishop on e5 attacking the rook
and now asking ourselves okay what
squares are now accessible to our pieces
noticing queen g5 and then finishing off
the pressure on the knight with the
brook c6
leading into checkmate um
well it depends on the weaknesses that
you create
captain jesus right if
if you're worried about getting lobster
pincered then don't play g6 right
because then your opponent could put a
bishop on f6
you need to understand whether there are
ways of making luft that don't create as
many weaknesses
okay wow i think you should ask that to
charlie
yeah i think i think we should reserve
that question for charlie
all right so that uh
concludes any questions about this game
well i mean i think black's last black's
last chance
i wouldn't take here i would play i
would play something like actually maybe
i would
i would try to castle long here maybe go
queen d7
actually maybe even castle short
although here i would go g4 to open up
the h file
um schwarzschild you asked that before
i'm not sure exactly what
what do you mean with kh3 i never put a
king on h3 so
if you mean bishop h3 then i explained
it i think in sufficient detail
the idea is to sacrifice on e6 increase
the pressure on the pawn
can you elaborate on why rook f5 well
basically it's all about understanding
what the
what the best attackers are this
position is so winning that either move
is good
but rook f5 i think is even better
because this bishop is a super valuable
attacker
and the fact that i sacrifice an
exchange shouldn't deter you because
look at the just the visual superiority
of my pieces over black's pieces
and look how important this bishop is
this bishop ties itself to the knight
it controls all of these squares and it
basically is responsible for this big
checkmate if this bishop weren't here
the king would be able to escape so i
was able to basically understand
that i was so close to delivering
checkmate the bishop would be a
very significant piece in the attack if
that makes sense
it's stronger than multiple black
strokes black strokes are just staring
at pawns
it's hard for me to explain that at a
level that perhaps is concrete enough
but that's basically the logic if that
makes sense
well it's hard to see but it's all about
not assuming things right when you
assume
oh i need to capture with the bishop
then you don't allow your brain
to process these kinds of things
and to me this is where intuition comes
in this is where experience comes in
right i'm able to just
judge this immediately because i've
attacked like this so many times
that um that to me there is no doubt in
my mind that this is completely winning
okay wittons well i'm not gonna even
attempt to pronounce that
okay it was spirit off playing oh he's
playing
okay let's go d4
let's go d4
and let's go with the queen's gambit
okay so queen's gambit accepted
now it's lacroix
what is the purpose of the queen's game
what is like the natural follow-up to
sacrificing the spawn
so what's like the obvious follow-up to
this like you you sacked the pawn to get
the center now e4 is not the only move
and there's also a drawback with e4
which is that you get your pawns to the
center
but you don't have any pieces develop
yet so this is actually one of the moves
that
is considered to be the main move and
now there's a lot of theory here but
the main move is to go knight f3 develop
the knight and support the pawn
taking on e5 leads to an undesirable
queen trade
okay so bishop before bishop d2 this is
theory and what ends up happening here
is you end up sacrificing the d4 pawn
you capture the c pawn but you get a big
lead in development so white is going to
have three pieces developed black is
going to have zero
but black takes the d4 pawn so now at
the end of the day black is up the pawn
but we've got to lead in development i
actually don't know the theory of this
too well
um but i think we will be able to
reconstruct
uh what we're supposed to do here so in
such positions i think
it's a good idea to not overthink it and
just continue developing
there's no need to do anything crazy so
if we were to just continue developing
what would that look like
yeah we could consider going queen b3
but but he could also defend that pawn
with queen e7 i'm not sure
that's worth it let's just castle let's
just castle
and let's see how he positions his
pieces that way we'll be able to make a
more informed decision about what to do
okay so bishop e6 um let's
well we can take the bishop and weaken
his king slightly i think that makes
sense and then we can go queen b3
uh we can also keep the tension with a
move like roxy and i do like the idea of
taking let's take here
okay he's taking his time on f66
all right um and then we have two pawns
both of which are undefended
so let's go queen v3 and attack both of
them and he can defend both of them with
queen c8
but then his queen becomes passive there
queen d7 is the move
okay so obviously i think most people
here would be like okay why not queen
takes b7
uh then he goes rook b8 we go queen a6
and maybe he takes back on b2 but
the end result of that is that the b
file gets opened
who benefits from the b file getting
opened who who benefits from that
ultimately
ultimately it's of course white it's
white because black is not castled yet
so when one side isn't castled open
files generally benefit the side that
has that leading development
okay let's go rook ac1 let's put the
rook on c1
okay attacking the knight trying to get
the knight to move if the knight moves
we win a7
so rook b6 is probably what he's going
to play
okay now where should we move the queen
where should we move the queen here what
should we do
yeah so queen a3 prevents him from
castling queen a3 prevents him from
castling so i like the idea of going
queen a3
now he could go queen e7 but then maybe
we shift the queen up to a4 and attack
the knight so we were trying to like get
him to
not castle we're trying to
exploit the fact that we have castled
and our opponent has not i think that
white is better here
and uh we're trying to milk that as much
as possible if we just let him castle
then he would complete his development
okay well this looks
very dubious because uh now he
permanently cannot cast
and now our goal is to improve the
positioning of our pieces
and to simply nurture the initiative so
what comes to mind
in that regard what what how can we
activate our pieces like what ideas
can we come up with here so one idea is
to go knight c4 and attack
and attack his is rook but i actually
like a slightly different plan here
what i like is the idea of doubling
rooks on the c file now why do i like
that the reason i like that
is because i want you guys to take a
good hard look at this knight on c6
okay this knight is not defended by any
pawns let's get
get this the heck out of there this
knight is not defended by any pawns
which means if we pile up the pressure
on that knight
that knight is very likely to end up in
super serious trouble if that knight
moves then we take on c7 so
we're basically keeping knight c4 in our
back pocket until the time is right for
that if it makes sense
as i say it's a pressure point exactly
okay so we have many ways now of
attacking the knight we can go queen a4
but we don't really want to trade queens
i don't want to do that
but now the move knight c4 is a whole
lot stronger
than it was previously although knight
c4 maybe rook b5 is kind of annoying so
let me think for a second how do we want
to do this how do we want to play this
let me think for a second how do we want
to play this position
well 95 he'll take it and and we don't
necessarily want to help him
absolve himself of that weakness
i'm thinking i'm thinking yeah knight g5
is interesting
okay let's go hmm let's go queen a4
let's go queen a4 and what i'm basically
gonna say is that
yes his knight is going to move but even
in the end game
oh this is a really good move though
this is a really good move
but uh we can just take here and what my
point is that even in the end game
the initiative continues uh this is a
point that is often very misunderstood
by people uh you can trade queens and
still be attacking that's not illegal
okay you can absolutely trade queens and
still be attacked so what should we do
now
we can actually win some material we can
play knight takes e5
and uh we have two pieces for rook i'll
explain the the
the complications after the game but
basically two pieces for a rook is good
for us
and um in terms of the pawn count we
also have
equal pawns so right now what's going on
here is we're attacking d4 we're
attacking c7
we need to consolidate our pieces make
sure this pass pawn doesn't go anywhere
but look at the piece activity we have
we have now the rook on the seventh ring
the rook can mow down some of these
pawns we're basically gonna play for
checkmate here
and um we're gonna have to be very
careful in how we
how we actually orchestrate that because
if we go knight 64 he goes rook takes f2
this guy is super super good
uh he's actually kind of tricked me a
little bit here hmm
let me think well d4 hanging but yeah
this guy is this guy is super annoying
let me think yeah
i had a bad feeling about this one okay
let's go knight c6
let's go knight c6 and let's play for
checkmate i'll explain what i'm doing
after the game
i'll explain what i'm doing like fully
after the game
okay now we're gonna go here we're going
to take on d4 that was the main idea of
knight c6 and take the pawn on our own
terms
to take the pawn on our own turns
okay now we're going to go here
and attack this pawn with our oh my god
i blundered
oh god i blundered uh i've wondered a
piece yeah he's going to win this one
that's going to be our first loss
yeah i had i had a feeling this guy was
going to beat me um
completely winning position too for
white but that's going to be our first
loss
yeah this guy somehow found a way out of
that situation
yeah it's that kind of an evening i
could just feel it let me try to come
back from this if you guys let me focus
let me try well this is completely
hopeless down in exchange just blended a
piece in one move
yeah i'm not sure like exactly what we
could have done this guy's playing
super super well
this guy is playing super well
no chances here just not leaving me a
single chance
interesting okay
taking a while on row page four
yeah he's got so much time
hmm
yeah okay but um you can count that as a
loss
that's just some magic i pulled but um
you can count that as basically a loss
okay um
okay i mean i am i am you know
i have you know i have to put the foot
down sometimes
okay
i have to put the foot down sometimes
that was weird i felt like we were
winning
but somehow he got out of it it was
really like hard to find the actual
the actual uh final blow
uh it was really weird i i'm i'm usually
good in these positions but i was not
able to like find anything specific
um you played unbelievably well i'll
check the accuracies
um and legitimately obviously not don't
take this the wrong way
i'm just curious where the win was
um well 95
for me 94.9 for me and
84.3 for him so we still played very
well i really only made one mistake
this entire game which was the blunder i
literally made one mistake which was the
blunder that was the only mistake
we made in this entire game everything
else was best every single other move
was best
so in a certain sense justice was served
he had made in one i don't think he did
um so i made this one blunder and
and that should have decided the game
okay
so basically let's go over the game
let's go over the game now this was a
queen's gambit
it was well played by him but it was
completely winning for white until the
blunder that's what i'm saying
well because i've wanted a piece i'll
explain it guys um
so knight f3 so so so this opening
is very theoretical there's there's a
lot to
there's a lot to unpack here um there's
a lot to unpack here and i don't want to
delve too deeply into the theory
basically yeah this is the queen's
gambit accepted
and what the battle revolves around is
well first of all black can try to cling
to the pawn of b5 this is a legitimate
line
but the problem with this entire setup
is that this pawn chain with the pawn on
v5 upon c4
uh is not sustainable and white is able
to chip away at the spawn chain
by force and the spawn chain just isn't
able to be sustained
so how does white do that how using the
principle of attacking the base of the
pawn chain
we go a4 black goes c6 if i goes a6
then at the end of the day he drops the
rook so black has to go c6
but the problem here is that after abcb
uh white goes knight c3
legos knight c3 and uh it's actually
very hard to defend the spawn
if black pushes the pawn then we can
pick it off with queen a4 queen takes
before if black goes a6 this is actually
a legitimate variation
uh there is a variation here where you
sack the exchange but
not everybody knows it what do we do
here with white
that was a very lucky game
yeah knight b5 is correct
and believe it or not there is a line
where black actually sacrifices the
exchange and then plays bishop takes e4
this is actually a legitimate variation
where black gets compensation for the
exchange
but uh white is still supposed to be
better here uh if blight knows what to
do here white gets an advantage
so uh this line does exist but that's
how
white reacts if black tries to cling to
the pawn so
most of black strategies revolve around
putting immediate pressure on white
center
and the reason he does that is because
white hasn't developed his pieces yet
if black lets white develop his pieces
um
then uh you're not going to have the
opportunity to attack white cena that
should be
kind of uh reasonable to you guys so e5
is
part of that strategy okay so d takes e5
here allows
black to take the queen and white loses
his castling rights
and the pawn count is equal so this is
no good for white that's why you go
knight f3 eat
bishop before check so d5 is not that
good
because you kind of close down the
center
and this is a variation this is a
legitimate line but black can get this
blockading square on d6 black just gets
a very solid position like this isn't
bad
but by closing up the center white
reduces the
effect let's say of his space advantage
and black gets uh
black gets nice blockade here you know
the square in front of an important pawn
if it's controlled by the opponent
that's kind of not a not a great thing
if that makes sense
yeah yeah of course so well the benefits
of accepting the gambit i mean this is a
very legitimate line for black
black doesn't get a bad position here if
he's very careful
okay so it takes takes um somebody asked
a question about queen a4 but this is a
check so
we have to deal with that yeah knight c3
is also a move like all of this is
theoretical
but the problem with knight c3 is it
allows this bishop to remain and sconced
on b4
and one thing that could could end up
happening is black could be using this
pin to his advantage
so i'm not exactly sure how but maybe c5
bishop d2 is more forceful right you are
removing
the only black piece that is developed
currently and right now we get the
situation this is a theoretical position
white's got three pieces above black as
zero white has full compensation for the
pawn
but if black is careful black should not
be worse here
so i'm not sure exactly where my
opponent went wrong but somewhere around
here he made a bad move
um and he goes bishop e6 which allows us
to
soften up the position around his king
also this pawn is very weak this spawn
is very weak
so we combine the two observations and
we go queen b3
my opponent decided to sacrifice the
pawn on b7 i think that was the main
mistake
this is the sort of position where if
you are already accepting the queen's
gambit
you know that that russian expression
having said a you have to say b
um if you're already accepting the
gambit then you might as well
cling to the pawn you might as well
suffer for a pawn
so queen c8 i think is a better move but
um
in a position like this i think white's
got very nice pressure for the pawn
like i think from a human perspective
this is a very pleasant position for
white
there's also ideas like knight c5 here
uh in
in the air and rook takes c6 ideas as
well so
i really like these positions for white
i think these positions are
suitable to my style but um
our opponent gives up b7 and he doesn't
reach out for b2
and the reason why is that he's just way
too underdeveloped here what would uh
what would i do in this position what is
an example of some of the moves
that white could play here to uh to you
know to sort of develop the initiative
and one thing to remember if you go rook
b1 uh black has kind of an annoying move
rook
back to b6 in my opinion this is kind of
annoying and
if you take on b6 black closes down the
b file so what you would want to do
first is go knight c4
to take away the b6 square and only
after the rook drops
back would you want to play rook a to b1
now you're winning the battle over the c
over the b file the rook has no good
squares no good save squares
to park itself on the b file and if
black ignores
this knight on c6 you guys should
already be aware of right this knight is
very vulnerable
this knight is also defending the rook
which means the knight is overloaded
what is a very simple way to take
advantage of this overloaded knight
and that is to play well queen c6 is
very creative but
uh then you sacrifice the queen and if
you actually calculate out the line
uh at the end of it black actually
recaptures the knight so it's less clear
but the simplest is knight e5 yeah 95 is
correct
attacking the queen if black takes then
you actually win both rooks
um so something like this could be the
consequence of him taking so he quickly
decides to develop
but in this position black is in big
trouble he can't castle
his position is very flimsy now rook c5
is really good
now why did i not play knight c4 i know
most people wanted to do this
well the bottom line reason and you've
got to be very careful about over
estimating these kinds of moves right
the problem with this move is that it
closes down the c
file it blocks our own biggest asset
which is rc file
so i wanted to keep this idea in my
pocket the threat is stronger than its
execution
that expression explains a lot of the
choices that i'm making here i'm trying
to build up the pressure
so that when i do play knight c4 it's
actually a lot stronger
i'm also like not sure maybe i don't
want to play knight c4 maybe i will one
play queen a4
which is what happened in the game the
knight on d2 also has the utility of
defending the e4 pawn so you don't want
to rush with these kinds of tempting
moves very important in my opinion
maintaining all control exactly that's
well said so knight g4 is just useless
now we double rooks and now queen a4 is
the best move actually
because it attacks the knight forces the
knight to move he moves it to e5 which
was kind of a
fancy move but uh no i wasn't because he
has no way to attack the rook he has no
actual way to attack the rook
if you were to like look at his knights
can his knights even hypothetically
attack the rook no
so not really um knight e5 is fancy but
at the end of the day it's the same
effect doesn't move like 98
obviously we cannot take the knight
because we drop our queen
so knight takes queen takes d7 and
knight e5 is also correct
basically at the end of the day now this
is something we need to unpack for a
second like he takes knight ft7
a lot of people got confused here
now okay queen d1 is a super
computer-ish move
uh this is not a human move at all to
drop the queen back is pretty crazy i
think queen e7 is fine
um why rook c5 rather than rook c2 or c5
is just a more active mode
okay rook c2 also could run into this so
roxy 5 is more
stable and it's more active and also
like the rook also controls the e5
square
so this is just objectively the best
score for the rook
now basically you need to
in these positions when there's a lot
going on you need to
break down exactly which pieces are
hanging and that
helps you get you know not as mystified
about
the complexities of the position so if
we are to like actually list out
all of the stuff that's hanging from
white's perspective only the rook and
the pawn
uh the knight on f3 is not hanging it is
protected by the knight and the pawn
um from black's perspective black has
three things that are hanging the knight
the pawn and the other pawn so we can
take c7
and if we calculate this line out yes
taking c7 is okay
but then after knight takes f3 knight
takes f3 and rook takes p2
a material is equal and now if we are to
take the other thing that's hanging
which is the d4 pawn
and we are to reevaluate the position
what does black have here what nasty
move
now becomes possible as a consequence of
the rook appearing here
and that's also a very important thing
to do you have to update your perception
of the position
what was once not hanging can now be
hanging where it takes f2
piggy's on the 7th black has a big
chance to deliver perpetual or even more
so in general two pieces for a rook
benefits the two pieces but also if you
just compare the activity of the two
knights versus the activity of the rooks
just visually speaking the knights are
running circles over these rooks
and black's got all these weak pawns so
i just determined that okay i'm probably
gonna win a bunch of white black spawns
and i'm probably gonna win the game here
also the king is very weak
king could literally get checkmated in
these positions so anyways he started
hunting after my pawns i started hunting
after his
and the critical moments so knight c6
now why did i play this move
dilmatic thank you again if we are to
take on d4 we blunder the pawn on f2
so i played knight c6 because i
potentially wanted to take the pawn with
this knight
and also i wanted to involve my other
knights in g fiber if i had to literally
deliver some sort of a checkmate
okay i literally wanted to go for
checkmate
and i was doing it all successfully up
until this point
so i checked the computer i i now know
what the best move was
and the best move was to go after this
epon
which i did but i did it in the wrong
way i forgot that this knight was not
overloaded
this knight is classic overloaded
defending two things at once
and he takes on d4 and um
instead i had a tactical way of going
after this pawn
which uh ex again bears the same idea as
rookie seven
and it's a tactical move so we actually
directly attack this one who can find it
it's a very pretty idea
it's knight to d8 yeah it's knight to d8
are we blundering the night no we're not
because this is a fork
against the king and the rock so we win
the game we win the rook in the game
and if he doesn't do anything then we
simply take on e6 and we just take all
of his pawns
we've got a devastating attack so this
is just winning this is a super nice
move
and it's not easy to see on demand but
this was the fastest way to win the game
definitely a five head move
but instead rookie seven of d4 and just
like that all of the effort has
evaporated and
white is lost that's that's the brutal
that's the reality of chess like you
you know you do everything perfectly and
then you play one very bad move
and and then you're you're busted you're
just down an exchange in a pawn
and it's only through a literal miracle
that i was able to win he kept taking
like 10 seconds of move
and somehow i managed to flag him but
for all intents and purposes
uh you know that was a loss
well i did take higaro if i take the
rook with the knight then he takes my
rook that's sort of the point of
putting the rook on e7 why it's bad it's
putting it in the cross crosshairs of
the king
and uh that is that is that game yeah a
lot a lot of stuff that happened
but hopefully uh hopefully i managed to
paint the general picture
of things that happened so anyways
that's that's what happened